looking for military intervention
intervention russia violated all our
legal system all international laws all
possible international laws they just
want to take us by force and control
don't
don't please prevent the new genocide of
ukrainians here and the only way how you
can do this
only by force
you know i never wanted anyone to kill
anyone i am the most peaceful person in
the world and ukrainians are but they
are just coming and they are just
killing us
so please stop them please come and save
us
all right uh that woman has become sort
of like an international rock star uh
she of course uh holed up in a shelter
right now uh in ukraine with her three
children and she's fighting the good
fight and says that the ukrainians will
never give up that fight joining me
right now is our former u.n ambassador
former director of national intelligence
so so much more john negroponte uh
ambassador good to have you the fight of
the ukrainian people is not in doubt
here that's for sure uh but i'm
wondering the more they show it and the
more frustrated vladimir putin gets
what next
yep uh good afternoon thanks for having
me on your
show neil yeah i i mean i wonder the
next thing because
putin having the kind of personality he
does
it makes me wonder whether he's just
going to throw more at it the more
resistance he gets
the more he'll throw at it and of course
in the end
russia is a larger more powerful country
got
a much stronger and bigger military and
ultimately even has nuclear weapons
uh not that
those are necessarily uh going to be
contemplated by mr putin although he's
made some
uh you know unfortunate gestures i think
but yeah i think there's a big risk out
there that
ultimately uh putin is going to just
inflict seek to inflict as much
punishment as he can on the country of
ukraine but that's not to say that we
haven't
done a lot to help i think both in terms
of military assistance i think the
response of europe
is uh really heartening and encouraging
uh you've seen a turnaround in a number
of different countries like germany now
willing to export
uh
lethal weapons to another country and
things like that
and of course we have to that point to
that point sir i'm sorry to jump in here
because i'm glad you mentioned it
because vladimir putin responded to that
he was stunned at germany deciding to do
that especially now germany breaks a
long argument of trying to avoid just
this sort of thing uh but he said that
if those getting here you use them i'm
paraphrasing you know watch out what can
he do to germany when he says watch out
well i don't know but it uh
the
the question arises well what about all
these countries that have decided to
help the ukrainians will mr putin look
for some way to retaliate against them i
think
that's harder to do and he's got his
hands full
uh at the moment but i mean the broader
point in a way
is whatever happens in ukraine
this series of events and this invasion
and i think has had a real uh
crystallizing and unifying effect in
europe in terms of their response
something that we could never do through
our powers of persuasion
mr
uh putin has managed to accomplish in
several days it's uh it's really quite a
startling
and dramatic change and i think you're
going to see uh
increased arms spending in western
europe you're going to see countries uh
some that are not members of nato
contemplating a closer relationship
with nato if not seeking to join it
there's going to be a whole series of
knock-on effects not all of which
we can yet uh anticipate but the
immediate question as you said is what
next
and i i would say what's next it's hard
to see
much farther than a day or two ahead in
these things i hate uh is more more
military pressure from the russians
all right uh ambassador thank you very
very much i apologize for a truncated
time here hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else